محمد
لو سمعت اسم النيجر في اي مكان مش هيجي في
بالك غالبا غير انها دوله افريقيه في مكان
ما دوله من الدول المنسيه الكثيره في
قارتنا المنهوبه المظلومه يمكن كمان نسبه
مننا بتتلخبط بينها وبين نيجيريا وكتير
مننا ممكن يغلطوا في مكانها على الخريطه
وده طبيعي دواء المنسيه زي ما قلت عند
معظمنا ما عدا حبايبنا في دول المغرب
العربي يمكن علشان جيران بطبيعه الحال لكن
الدول دي هي يمكن اهم دول القاره ومن
اهمهم النيجر اللي مساحتها تقريبا قد
مساحه مصر مره وربع واكتر من 98% من
سكانها مسلمين
طب ليه النيجر مهمه لانه رغم انها للاسف
تالت افقر دوله في العالم بعد جنوب
السودان وتشاد ورغم مناخها شديد القسوه
وارضها اللي بتتعرض للجفاف والتصحر بشكل
دوري الا انها عندها موارد طبيعيه مهوله
كنوز كامله بتعوم عليها زي ما هنوضح بعد
شويه من اقل من 3 اسابيع يوم 26 يوليو
اللي فات ده النيجر رجعت على الخريطه تاني
وبقت على رادار معظم ان لم يكن كل سكان
الوطن العربي والعالم بلا مبالغه ايه اللي
حصل صحينا من النوم لقينا الجنرال عبد
الرحمن تشاني قائد الحرس الرئاسي انقلب
على رئيس النيجر وحليف فرنسا القوي محمد
بازو واطاح بيه من السلطه في وسط تصاعد
التوترات والاستياق الشعب العام من
ممارسات الاستعماريه الفرنسيه في البلد
علشان كده اول حاجه المتظاهرين الداعمين
للانقلاب عملوها انهم زحفوا على مقر
السفاره الفرنسيه في اعتراضات واسعه على
وجود فرنسا السياسي العسكري على ارض
النيجر وعلى سرقتها لثروات البلد خاصه
اليورانيوم لكن جرايم فرنسا مش مقتصره بس
على سرقه الثروات النيجر الطبيعيه وانما
على كارثه كبيره سايباها لاهلنا في النيجر
اسمها النفايات المشعه فايه اللي بيحصل
بالظبط في النيجر وايه الكارثه اللي
عملتها فرنسا في واحد من اكبر مناجم
اليورانيوم في العالم هناك وازاي النيجر
بقت عايمه على بحر من النفايات المشعه
اسئله مهمه وخطيره هنحاول نجاوب عليها
واكتر في حلقه النهارده اللي لازم تشوفوها
على الاخر انا اشرف ابراهيم المقبل
الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
عايز اشكر شركه العالميه لرعايتها الحلقه
دي وهي شركه عندها خبره طويله في الاسواق
الماليه بحجم تداولات شهريه تجاوز الاتنين
تريليون دولار ليه بنصح بالتعامل مع اكس
علشان اربع مميزات الاولى انها مرخصه
ومراقبه من هيئات رقبيه التانيه بعرف اسحب
فلوسي فيها بشكل فوري بدون تدخل بشري
الثالثه ان عملتهم منخفضه الرابعه ان
التداول بيتنفس بسرعه تقدر تفتح حساب
اسلامي لا محدود وتبدا تشتري وتبيع الاسهم
والدهب هتلاقوا لينك لهم تحت الفيديو وفي
تعليقات فيسبوك دي النيجر شعب من افقر
شعوب الارض نسمع دمه بيكافحوا يوميا علشان
يعرفوا ياكلوا ويلاقوا ميه نضيفه يشربوها
42% من السكان دول بيعيشوا في فقر و60%
منهم بيعانوا من حاجه اسمها الحرمان
المتعدد يعني محرومين من الخدمات الصحيه
والتعليميه والمياه والصرف الصحي واسكان
ادمي والقدره على التملك السكن ده لو لقوه
او اي اصل تاني بالاضافه للكهرباء ده كل
رغم ان النيجر فيها موارد طبيعيه مهوله
وعلى راسها اليورانيوم والدهب النيجر يا
اخواننا هي سابع اكبر منتج لليورانيوم في
العالم لكن دوله واحده بس تقريبا هي اللي
مسيطره على عمليات استخراج اليورانيوم
وبتاخده برخص التراب الدوله دي طبعا هي
فرنسا ثروه شعب النيجر هي اللي بتنور بيوت
الفرنسيين وبتدفيهم وبتشغل مصانعهم لو
فاكرين مبالغ فيكفي تعرفه انه من تلاته من
كل اربع مصابيح في فرنسا بتضاء من خلال
يورانيوم النيجر لان اليورانيوم ده هو
اللي بيغذي مفاعلاتها النوويه اللي مسؤوله
عن توليد 70% من الكهرباء الفرنسيه
اليورانيوم هو واحد من اهم واخطر العناصر
الطبيعيه في العالم بعد استخراجه بيمر
بمراحل علشان ناخد منه اكسيد اليورانيوم
المركز ده مسحوق اصفر بيحتفظ به في براميل
ونشاطه خفيف ومعروف باسمه الاكثر شهره
الكعكه الصفراء وهو اللي بيستخدم بعد
معالجته مره تانيه في صناعه وقود
المفاعلات النوويه واليورانيوم عموما ممكن
يستخدم برضو في انتاج القنابل
الهيدروجينيه والاسلحه النوويه وفي العلاج
الاشعاعي لبعض انواع السرطان ربنا يحفظكم
وممكن كسابوره لبعض السفن علشان يعمل لها
توازن والبعض انواع الطائرات برضو
وبيستخدم في بعض انواع الذخيره والضروع زي
دروع الدبابات سعر اكسيد اليورانيوم او
الكعكه الصفراء في السوق العالميه يوم 30
يوليو اللي فات كان 56 دولار و23 سنت
للرتله الواحد يعني الكيلو جرام بيعمل
تقريبا 130 دولار لو بصينا على خريطه
الانتاج العالمي من اليورانيوم في 2022
هنلاقي كازاخستان هي اللي بتستحوس على
الحصه الاكبر من انتاج اليورانيوم العالمي
ثم كندا ثم تيجي ناميبيا ثم استراليا
واسباكستان
روسيا ثم النيجر ثم بقيت العالم النيجر
لحد سنه 2015 كانت رابع اكبر منتج
لليورانيوم عالميه لكن الانتاج انخفض في
السنين اللي بعد كده لحد ما وصلت للمركز
السابع زي ما شفته انتاجها في 2022 تم
استخراجه من مانجم واحد بس هو منجم سمير
ده منجم اليورانيوم الوحيد اللي شغال
دلوقتي في النيجر المنجم ده عباره عن
مواقع تعدين مفتوحه قريبه من مدينه ارللت
في الشمال الغربي بيدير المانجم ده شركه
اسمها سمير ودي شركه مملوكه بنسبه
63.4% لشركه اورانو الفرنسيه والنسبه
الباقيه مملوكه لشركه سوبر مان وهي شركه
تابعه لحكومه النيجر ومسؤوله عن انشطه
التعدين في الدوله قبل ما نكمل طبعا لازما
اقول لكم سريعا مين هي اورانو هي الشركه
الفرنسيه المسيطره على انشطه التعدين
اليورانيوم في النيجر وواخده تقريبا كل
ثروه البلد منه شركه اورانو كان اسمها
اريفا قبل 2018 وهي شركه عملاقه وواحده من
اكبر شركات انتاج الوقود النووي في العالم
واغلبيتها مملوك للحكومه الفرنسيه في 2021
اورانو كانت تالت اكبر شركه منتجه
لليورانيوم في العالم استحوست على 11% من
الانتاج العالمي الشركه دي يا اخوانا هي
زراعه فرنسا اللي بتنهب من خلالها ثروه
النيجر من اليورانيوم من اكتر من 40 سنه
تطلعوا برخصه تراب وتدفع في مبالغ لا تذكر
للحكومات النيجر وتبعته لفرنسا علشان تشغل
مفاعلاتها نوويه علشان كده الانقلاب اللي
حصل في النيجر واطاح بمحمد بازون وحكومته
كان كارثه للفرنسيين طب ليه هل لان النظام
الجديد ده هيعادي فرنسا الحقيقه الموضوع
مش كده احنا لسه منعرفش ايه اللي هيحصل في
اللي جاي وما نقدرش نجزم حاليا رغم بوادر
افعال نظام النيجر الجديد المعاديه تماما
للوجود الفرنسي على اراضي النيجر ورغم انه
منع تصدير اليورانيوم والذهب لفرنسا وقطع
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه معها لكن
بشكل عام خايفين من اللي هيحصل واللي ممكن
ياثر على استمرار شفطهم لايرانيوم النيجر
اللي بيعتبر مورد مهم ورئيسي لتشغيل السته
وخمسين مفاعل نووي المتوزعين على 18 محطه
طاقه عندهم المفاعلات النوويه الفرنسيه دي
بتاكل حوالي 8000 طن يورانيوم سنويه
الترسانه النوويه الجباره دي مش بس بتولد
70% من الكهرباء الفرنسيه المحليه لكنها
مخليه فرنسا اكبر مصدر صافي للطاقه
النوويه في العالم وده بيدخلها اكتر من
ثلاثه مليار يور سنويا المايجر تعتبر احد
اكبر ثلاث موردين لليورانيوم لفرنسا
وساهمت في اخر 10 سنين بحوالي 20% من
الاحتياجات الفرنسيه لو رجعنا لمناجم
اليورانيوم في النيجر ودور اورانو
الفرنسيه فيها هنلاقي ان المانجم الثاني
اللي لسه قائد التطوير هو منجم ايمورال
اللي بيحتوي على واحد من اكبر احتياطيات
اليورانيوم في العالم المنجم بيقع على بعد
ميل جنوب مدينه ارلند والخبراء بيتوقعوا
ان المنجم ده هينتج 5000 طن من رواسب
اليورانيوم سنويا على مدار 35 سنه جايه
ورغم ان شركه اورانو الفرنسيه اخدت تصريح
تشغيل المنجم ده سنه 2009 الا انها وقفت
شغل في سنه 2014 بعد انهيار اسعار
اليورانيوم بسبب كارثه فوكشيما اليابانيه
سنه 2011 لو رحنا لموقع الشركه الالكتروني
هنلاقيها بتقول انه هيتم تشغيل
بمجرد ما ظروف السوء تسمح بده هنا هتظهر
لنا علامات استفهام ضخمه عن سبب عدم سحب
حكومات النيجر المتعاقبه ترخيص تشغيل
المنجم من شركه اورانو رغم انه بقى لها 14
سنه ما طلعتش جرام واحد يورانيوم منه اللي
لفت انتباهي اكتر في كلام الشركه عن
المنجم في تقريرها عن انشطه التعدين
بتاريخ سبتمبر 2022 ان الشركه لسه حاطه
الموقع تحت البحث والتطوير علشان تقيم
جدوى تشغيله واست اليورانيوم منه بطرق
استخراج مختلفه اللي ورا كلام الشركه
الفرنسيه المختصر ده اللي وراه هنلاقيه في
تقرير نشرته دوريه الاستخبارات الشهيره
افريكانز في اوائل فبراير اللي فات كشفت
فيه اورانو بتدعي وركزوا في الكلام ان
استخراج اليورانيوم من هناك غير ممتي من
الناحيه الاقتصاديه بسبب انخفاض اسعار
المعدن دلوقتي طبعا ده كلام مش صحيح لان
الاسعار اللي وضحناها قبل كده اللي هي 130
دولار لكيلو اليورانيوم الواحد مش اسعار
قليله بدليل ان شركه اورانو نفسها حققت
ارباح في 2021
باربعه فاصل سبعه مليار يورو يعني ما
يعادل خمسه ونصف مليار دولار ومتوسط اسعار
اليورانيوم في السنه دي كان تقريبا نص
الاسعار الحاليه طب ايه الهدف من الدعاءات
الشركه الفرنسيه يبدو وده الارجح في رايي
ان الشركه بتماطل في تفعيل حق الانتفاع
بالمنجم واستخرجوا اليورانيوم علشان
تستخدم طريقه مثيره للجدل في استخراجه
خفض التكاليف وبالتالي تحقيق ارباح اكبر
بكلمكم تحديدا عن تقنيه اسمها
والمعروفه اختصارا دي تقنيه لاستخراج
اليورانيوم من باطن الارض لكن بدون حفر
وتحريك اطنان من التربه زي الطريقه
التقليديه المتعارف عليها اللي بيحصل هنا
انهم بيضخوا محلول حمض في الارض علشان
يدوب اليورانيوم الموجود في الرواسب بعدها
بيسحبوا السائل ده لمصنع معالجه
وبيستخرجوا منه اليورانيوم ميزه الطريقه
دي بالنسبه لشركات التعدين انها بتقلل
عليها تكاليف الاستخراج لكن من الناحيه
التانيه بتتسبب في كارثه بيئيه لاصحاب
الارض نفسهم لانها بتلوث الارض والمياه
الجوفيه باليورانيوم اللي هو عنصر سام زي
ما كلنا عارفين بطريقه ملهاش علاج اللي
بتفكر تعمله شركه اورانو الفرنسيه في
النيجر مش اول سبقه سيئه لها في سابقه
اسوا عملها بالفعل مش مجرد تفكير كمان
عملوها في المنجم التالت في النيجر
بيعتبر من اكبر مناجم اليورانيوم في
العالم هو منجم اكوتا ده منجم قريب من
مدينه التعدين في جنوب غرب ارلت المانجم
ملك لشركه اللي غالبيتها مملوك لشركه
اورانو فضلت اورانوس تخرج منه يورانيوم من
سنه 1978 وعلى مدار 43 سنه لحد ما استنفذت
جميع احتياطياتهم من الخام وقررت تقفله في
مارس 2021 المنجم ده انتج 75 الف طن
مليورانيوم في فتره عمره دي سنه 2014 نشرت
رويترز تقرير صادم اطلعت فيه على وثائق
بتكشف ان المناجم اللي بتسيطر عليها شركه
اريفا وقتها ورانو حاليا ما بتدفعش رسوم
تصدير على اليورانيوم المستخرج منها ولا
ضرائب على المواد والمعدات اللي بيدخلوها
البلد علشان يستخدموها في عمليات التعديل
كل اللي بتدفعه اول عن اخر ضريبه هزيله
قيمتها خمسه ونصف في الميه على اليورانيوم
المنتج ده مثال بسيط بيوضح الممارسات
الاست
المنجم بينتجوا غاز مشع بيعرف باسم رادون
نتيجه التحلل الطبيعي لليورانيوم الرادون
هو غسان جدا لو استنشق بجرعات مركزه
ويعتبر تاني اكتر مسبب لسرطان الرئه في
الولايات المتحده مثلا بعد السجاير لو
اتكلمنا عن مدخنين لكن بين غير المدخنين
هو السبب رقم واحد اللي بيحصل ان رياح
الصحراء القويه بتنشر الغبار المشع ده
والسكان اللي ساكنين حوالين المنجم في
المدينتين بيستنشقوه بنسب مختلفه مش كده
بس ده بيلوث التربه والمياه كمان المشكله
الاكبر ان المكان بالنفايات النوويه ده
قريب من الاراضي الزراعيه وبالتالي ممكن
يؤدي لتسمم الطعام اللي بيستهلكوا السكان
دول منظمه جنين بيس البيئيه العالميه
الشهيره في الكم سنه اللي فاتوا لما تم
السماح لها بالدخول بقت تعمل اختبارات
وبحوث حوالين جوده التربه والميه والهواء
فيها كوكا دراساتهم اثبتت ان تركيز
الاشعاع اعلى بحوالي 500 مره من الطبيعي
وحذره من ان قضاء ساعه واحده في اليوم على
مدار سنه في الموقع ده بيعرض الانسان لعشر
اضعاف جرعه الاشعاع السنويه وده عكس
تصريحات مسئول الشركه اورانو بالمناسبه
اللي بياكدوا ان مستويات الاشعه طبيعيه
لقت كمان قطع خرده معدنيه مشعه بتتباع في
السوق المحلي في جرعه الاشعاع في القطع دي
كانت اعلى ب 50 مره من مستويات العاديه
ولما بداوا يحللوا عينات الميه لا ان كل
اربع عينات من اصل خمس عينات جمعوها من
منطقه كان تركيز اليورانيوم فيها اعلى من
الحد الاوسط به منظمه الصحه العالميه ومش
كده بس ده ما بقاش في مياه جوفيه لان شركه
اورانو استخدمت حوالي 270 مليار لتر من
الميه على مدار اكتر من 40 سنه من
العمليات جوه المانجا وبالتالي طبقه
المياه الجوفيه اللي كان عمقها اكتر من
150 متر بقت جافه حيوانات الرعي نفسها
بدا التمرد بسبب تلوث المراعي بالغبار
المشع باختصار وفقا للنشطاء البيئه
فالكارسل البيئيه اللي اتسببت فيها شركه
اورانو الفرنسيه في منطقه منجم اكوتا لحد
دلوقتي تكلفتها الحقيقيه ممكن توصل
لمليارات الدولارات طبعا اورانو زي ما قلت
لكم بتنفي كل الكلام ده وبتقول احنا زي
الفل وسكان النيجر زي الفل مهندس الطاقه
النوويه الفرنسي من مختبر القراد بيقول ان
اورانو بتكذب على الناس لانها بتقول انها
قاست مستويات التلوث في الميه وما لقتش
حاجه في حين ان قياسات المختبر على نفس
الميه بتظهر مستويات خطيره من التلوث طبعا
تاثير كل ده بقى واضح على صحه السكان اللي
عايشين في المنطقه جمعيه اجر مان وهي
جمعيه محليه غير ربحيه في النيجر بتقول ان
في زياده في حالات الامراض الشديده بين
عمال المناجم ذكوره واناث واكثر امراض
شائعه هي اضطرابات الجهاز الهضمي والسرطان
والعقم وتشوهات الولاده والاجهاض وغيرها
ولان شركه اورانو بتقدم دعم مالي لبعض
المستشفيات في مدن التعدين دي فالاطباء
وادارات المستشفيات دي ما بيقدروش يقولوا
ان الامراض دي وبالذات سرطان الرئه مرتبطه
بالنشاط الاشعاعي الامين العام السابق
اتحاد طلاب جامعه ميامي محمود سمايله
بيقول انه غالبا بيتم خداع المرضى من قبل
الاطباء اللي بيقولوا لهم انهم مصابين
بفيروس نقص المناعه البشريه الايدز وده مش
صحيح لان غالبيه الحالات المرضيه دي
مرتبطه بالنشاط الاشعاعي الطبيعي اللي كان
المفروض شركه اورانو تعمله من وقت ما قفلت
المانجم انها هتقفله بشكل امن وتدفن
النفايات المشعه بالطرق المتبعه عالميه
لكن ده ما حصلش لحد دلوقتي طب ليه ما
عملتوش كده من بدري يا جماعه قال لك هنعمل
لسه جايين اهو شركه كومناك اتبع لشركه
اورانو بتقول انها بتخطط لبناء وعاء
لتامين المخلفات وهتغطيه بطبقه من الطين
والصخور بطول مترين لاحت الاشعاع طبعا
الموضوع مكلف هيوصل ل 160 مليون دولار
وهيوعدوا عشر سنين يعملوا فيه قبل ما
يسلموا الموقع لحكومه النيجر وبجانب ان
السكان عندهم شك ان الشركه هتعمل ده فعلا
لانهم ببساطه
هنلاقي ان في تخوفات تانيه عندهم من ان
الطبقه الاورانو هتغطي بها النفايات محتمل
ما تصمتش وتصاب بتشققات بالذات قدام
الفيضانات اللي بتحصل والفكره انه لو حصل
تصدعات في غزل المسبب للسرطان هيتسرب
ويختلط بالمياه وهيوصل لكل مكان عن طريق
الفيضانات دي لحد هنا انا خلصت كلامي مش
عاوز اطول عليكم اكتر من كده نتمنى
السلامه لكل اهلنا في النيجر ويا ريت
متابعينا هناك يطمنونا في التعليقات عليهم
ربنا يعدي ايامكم على خير والاوضاع تستقر
في اقرب وقت وكالعاده هختم بسؤال لحضراتكم
تفتكروا الانقلاب اللي حصل ممكن ينهي
التواجد الفرنسي على الاراضي النيجيريه
بشكل نهائي ولا نفوس فرنسا هناك اقوى من
اللي حصل هتابع كل اجاباتكم في التعليقات
اللي عايز يشتري اسهم او ذهب ما تنسوش
تشوفوا شركه اكسنس هتلاقوا رابط تحت
الفيديو ما تنسوش تشتركوا في القناه ويا
ريت لو عجبتكم الحلقه تعملوا لايك وشير
للفيديو واهم حاجه تحكوا لاصحابكم
وحبايبكم عننا يمكن نستفيدوا سلام
[موسيقى]